- When my little brother Lucas was born,
my parents were told that
he wouldn't walk or talk
and the doctors even
said he might not make it
to his tenth birthday.
But today, a few months away
from his tenth birthday,
we're doing our fifteenth
triathlon together.
My name is Noah Aldrich,
and this is my brother, Lucas Aldrich.
- (vocalizing)
- Lucas, you've gotta stop talking.
Gotta get the guy, Luke.
- Noah is 11, and Lucas is nine,
and Lucas was born with
a rare genetic neurologic
condition called lissencephaly.
He's unable to walk, unable to talk,
he's unable to feed himself,
but despite all of his challenges,
he's the happiest little
boy that you'll ever meet.
- About four years ago,
our boys started doing
triathlons together, and most cases
that wouldn't be a big deal,
a lot of kids do triathlons,
but there's something
very special about the way
our boys do triathlons.
- I pull Lucas in a raft
for the swim portion.
Then, I pull him in a bike
cart during the bike.
And I push him in a running
cart during the run.
I wanted to do this because
Lucas can't do things
like we can.
He can't really play sports,
so this is something we can do together.
Currently, we're training
for our fifteenth triathlon,
which is this weekend.
Before the race I always feel nervous.
I don't think I'll ever get over that.
I just don't want to hurt Lucas.
I don't care if I win the race,
he just has to be okay.
- [Alissa] Before the
race, Lucas gets serious
and he gets his race face on
and they're ready to compete.
[Crowd] Two, one!
(crowd cheering)
- [Alissa] They swim around 200 yards.
Then they transition to a bike.
They'll go usually about
three to five miles.
- [Brian] And then
they'll run about a mile.
Noah's strong physically
and especially mentally.
Because he's truly only doing these races
for his brother.
- [Noah] Sometimes I feel like, God,
it's gotta be over soon, right?
But I just hear Lucas.
- [Lucas] (vocalizing)
- [Noah] That's how he says, “Go faster".
- [Kid] Come on, go go go!
- [Woman] Go, buddy, go go go! Nice!
(cowbell ringing)
- Every day is precious
with that little boy.
I try to soak in the experience,
because we don't know how long the boys
will be able to do triathlons together.
Any one of them could be their last.
What these boys accomplish gives me
an immense sense of pride.
- Noah and Lucas are an inspiration.
People see these two young boys,
and it gives them hope and
it gives them encouragement
to go out and tackle life challenges.